Carlton:
You think that you know
about what happened during
Hurricane Katrina?
♪♪
You actually really don't.
Vera:
Five Days At Memorial is a show
about doctors and nurses
Vera:
in a hospital, in New Orleans,
during Hurricane Katrina,
who find themselves
forced to make life and death
choices under extreme duress.
♪♪
Sheri:
For me as the journalist,
the important thing isn't to
judge, it's to find out what
really happened.
Sheri:
Not making one person a hero
and one person a victim.
Sheri:
Nurses, doctors, patients,
they were stuck in a horrific
circumstance that was
Sheri:
not their fault.
Cornelius:
And what made Memorial stand
out is the bodycount.
Carlton:
After the water was pumped out
of the city,
people went into this hospital
and found 45 dead bodies.
How did that happen and who was
responsible for that?
A hospital that size,
maybe 45 patients just
succumbed.
Maybe they didn't.
Vera:
They keep assuming that someone
is going to come and help them.
Someone from the city, someone
from the state, someone from the
federal government, FEMA.
We have to consider patients
that we can't evacuate.
Dr. Mulderick:
We're running out of food and we
will be out of fresh water by tomorrow.
Life is gray, and when you're in
the position of making life and
death decisions, it's even grayer.
Power's out and the water is
rising.
Without power, it's not a
hospital, it's just a building.
Dr. Mulderick:
We need to discuss who's going
first and who's going last.
Cornelius:
We all have different
perspectives about about what's right and what's wrong.
I can't imagine having to make
those decisions and be
ultimately responsible.
It's a horrible circumstance
when doctors are sort of forced
to play god.
♪♪
Sheri:
I believe that the viewer can
have an opinion.
There's no easy answers.
♪♪
Carlton:
You have to give the audience
the opportunity
Carlton:
to not just be an observer but
also a participant.
I can evac one person.
-One?
-One, hurry!
What would you do? What
decisions would you make?
These people were heroes.
They did save hundreds of
patients' lives.
♪♪
Vera:
But they also had to make
horrible decisions.